bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous quel regard portez-vous sur cette
affaire
bonjour d'abord à condamner fermement
les actes intolérables qui ont été
commis sur la personne de monsieur
jamais maire de val de reuil que quand
on s'attaque à renée lions s'attaquent à
la république au même titre que quand on
s'attaque aux forces de l'anp voilà donc
c'est dommage
c'est une symbolique forte que dans
farine et un élu de cette manière
tout à fait une symbolique forte étant
donné que c'est un élu de la république
donc encore une fois et s'est montré une
certaine défiance envers l'état
on voit en tout cas que la ligue de
défense nord africaine serait à
l'origine de cet enfermement du maire
alors il ya une réaction de gérald
darmanin puisqu'on apprend aujourd'hui
qu'il a lancé une procédure de
dissolution est ce que c'est une bonne
solution à apporter à ces tensions qui
sont donc le déroulé qui ont commencé il
ya déjà plusieurs jours et qui sont
arrivés à leur paroxysme samedi
visiblement
que je connais pas assez de défense nord
africaine pour le juger maintenant les
propos inacceptables et discours
racistes xénophobes et sont à condamner
fermement maintenant je pense que si
monsieur darmana a demandé la
dissolution ce qui doit avoir des
éléments à charge est-ce que des choses
n'auraient pas aussi dû être faite le
jour où c'est insultes racistes ont été
prononcés avant qu'on arrive samedi à
l'invasion de la mairie
et l'enfermement du maire
je peux pas vous dire j'étais pas sur
place maintenant
on est surtout on essaie surtout
d'apaiser le climat actuel donc je sais
pas comment ça a été géré mais les
collègues étaient présentes sur place et
ont pout dessus de son plus petit
intervenu bien merci beaucoup jouer de
manger pour toutes ces précisions je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
départemental du syndicat unité police
sgp police 27 merci à vous